when you went up for your Oscar speech
was there part of you that was thinking
it's about effing time or was there
because you're so humble everybody's so
sweet and nice when they get these
speeches and your message of the call
your mom and call your mom call your mom
it was just I mean it resonated but I
mean
were you kind of like did you feel it
I've always felt like I didn't belong
like I don't belong here I don't belong
in Hollywood did you did you ever feel
like I don't really belong here I don't
really belong with this or you know what
was your feelings when you went up on
stage no I I still feel like I don't
belong yeah um and I I mean I I didn't
there was there was no you know it's
about time
that ever entered my mind and I've had a
complicated relationship
going back to Childhood with the whole
concept of awards for you know Artistic
Endeavors and and uh you know that's a
whole different podcast
um right but uh it was basically
everybody that I knew who who really
understands the ins and outs of of
awards season and all of that I mean
everybody said dude there's no way it's
not going to be you so there was and I'd
won every trophy you know two trophies a
week in the in the two months leading up
to that so it was
you know it was it was like if they if
they say and the Oscar goes too and they
don't say my name I'm a schmuck you know
because because that's that's the
expectation right you know
um so it was uh uh you know it was
almost a release when when they did say
it and then and then as had been my want
that that whole award season you know I
I never wrote
quote unquote wrote a speech
I didn't know exactly what I was gonna
say all I knew was the theme
you know what I wanted to focus on which
which in that case was was you know
what's really important which is family
and yeah uh started out talking about my
my wife and and thanking her for for
everything that she is and
and there are kids who were in the in
the balcony and uh
and then their relationship you know her
being such an extraordinary mother which
led me to talk about uh you know my mom
our moms everybody's mom and dad and you
know that how important those all those
relationships are and it was really
you know maybe the most rewarding aspect
of my
career that was certainly the biggest
audience I was ever in front of you know
I mean you know a hundred times more
people saw the Oscars than saw whiplash
so you know I was reaching this broad
audience and and uh and the feedback
that I got from that I mean from from
comical to uh to like deeply moving to
life-altering interactions that people
had with their parents as a result of
some you know journeyman bald character
actor telling them to call their mom and
dad you know it was amazing